c'était un rêve d'enfant pour romain
devenir policier pourtant après
l'obtention de son bac pro il ne pense
pas avoir les capacités pour réaliser
son rêve
pendant six ans il fait plusieurs petits
boulots jusqu'au jour où il décide de
revenir à sa première passion
il n'était pas heureux dans mon travail
un pas du tout donc je m'ennuyais j'ai
besoin de faire un métier où j'étais
fier de moi quand je rentrais le soir à
part me dire j'ai vendu des vêtements
voilà pas de côtières et en
réfléchissant et c'est en me renseignant
voilà j'ai découvert que je pouvais
intégrer la police nationale le métier
d'agent de sécurité pour être sûr de peu
de tromper un ads et c'est parfait c'est
une langue durant ce moment c'est
pourquoi c'est un must à dire qu'on est
contractuel c'est un contrat de trois
ans si ça nous plaît pas eh bien on
arrête tout simplement c'est pas comme
ça n'était gaza nappe est donc titulaire
il intègre à la suite d'un concours le
commissariat de versailles où il est
vite intégré et comment ces missions
dans les missions sont variées donc ça
peut être de la guerre de statique une
garde de portes des locaux de la
surveillance une carte de personnalités
ensuite de la patrouille
donc on répond aux appels 17 de la pluie
secours pure et également du travail
d'initiative
on va pouvoir faire du contrôle routier
fer d'interpellations si on constate un
délit ou autre donc vraiment ces divers
la jeune recrue arrive à la fin de sa
formation il souhaite continuer sa
carrière dans la police nationale
son nouveau rêve devenir lieutenant dans
la police judiciaire